all right welcome back everybody we are
back um it's april we're back from
vacation
and i think it's important now that
we're back from vacation
for a few days before our next six month
vacation
that's a joke by the way we're we're
really back we actually are back um
to talk about something that's sort of
splitting the audience the audience is
in a sense divided
about coverage of the former president
donald trump the talking about the
former president donald trump
uh since the end of his presidency is
now several months
in in history i am here to tell you
that for shows like ours
it would be irresponsible not to cover
donald trump
in a very specific sense now we cover
many different things on this program we
cover
world politics and science the pandemic
and medical research
technology interviews with cultural and
psycho
psychology experts sociology so many
different things
but fundamentally we cover american
politics
and there are two main parties in the
united states like it or not and i don't
like it
those two parties are democrats and
republicans and for now
most republicans support donald trump 75
million of them
voted for donald trump just months ago
donald trump's
presence in american politics his role
over the next two years will determine
the future of the republican party how
do i do a show
about american politics and not cover
trump
there's a case to be made and i've made
it myself
that with trump gone his statements need
not be regarded with any particular
respect or deference merely because
he's the former guy uh 99
percent of what donald trump said while
president made no sense his instincts
were uniformly terrible
he mismanaged just about everything that
he
uh got involved in so there there's no
doubt whatsoever
about that piece we see him as a failed
former president
trump is a former president and he's
also in a sense a guy who got just about
everything wrong
but to do what some want done
which is to ignore trump pretend he
never happened pretend he has no more
role to play in american politics when
the republican party
still mostly defers to him and
republican voters still mostly support
him
would be silly and it would sort of be
pretending to live in a world that's
different from the one we actually live
in we don't do that with flat earthers
we don't do that with anti-vaxxers so we
can't pretend that donald trump is now
irrelevant it's also important to cover
the continued scandals because it needs
to continually be used
to put pressure on the republicans who
still defend donald trump
later in today's show as an example i'm
going to tell you about a massive
trump fundraising scam which has just
been exposed
that has completely blown up in donald
trump's face and in the faces of
republicans
they were surreptitiously charging
people's credit cards almost like a
subscription
which you might expect with a cable bill
or a cell phone bill but not with a
political donation
it's outrageous it has to be exposed it
has to be known
trump after real here's another example
after railing against cancel culture
right alongside republicans for months
or years now
trump is now demanding boycotts of a
list of nearly a dozen companies and
organizations
that's a massive laughable cartoonish
hypocrisy
where the republican party is complicit
and we have to report that
so bottom line i would like for trump
never to have happened
going back to 2015-26 sadly
the republican electorate in and here's
a way in which it's very different than
the democratic electorate
the republican electorate was bamboozled
into supporting donald trump trump ran
as a democrat it never would have
happened
and we are where we are today i would
like for donald trump to have no more
influence over american politics but
unfortunately
republican voters that same ignorance
that led them to fall for trump five
years ago
has led them to continue supporting
donald trump today for the most part
so the reality i wish to be true the
reality most of you wish to be true
which is that trump never happened
it's not reality and to pretend it is as
some kind of
protest by pretending trump is saying
nothing and doing nothing and wielding
no power at all
particularly when he's slowly inching
and crawling his way back into politics
now that it's been a few months
since he officially left office that
would be irresponsible so we can't
do that i think the the the goal should
be
to couch everything that donald trump is
doing
in the context of what does this mean
for the future of the republican party
is this a party that is saying that was
a mistake and we have to distance from
it
so far they are not and that's arguably
the biggest story
right now so um that's my perspective at
this point in time i know different
shows are taking different approaches
but for me
i can't pretend things are different
than what they are
and right now the republican party is
still
heavily a pro-trump party and
one in which until another leader comes
forward
is still essentially deferring to donald
trump
on most issues and we're going to look
at some examples of that later today
but first let's talk about this
incredible incredible fundraising scam
that has completely collapsed today's
episode is sponsored by
bluechew a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost and they're giving my audience an
entire month's
supply for free take a short quiz on the
bluechew website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription
and the medication goes right to your
home in a discreet package no driving to
the doctor's office
having a possibly awkward conversation
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluechu replaces the entire process with
a few
clicks and way less expensive and all of
blue chews tablets are made
in the united states so if you think you
could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
go to bluechew.com the link is under
this video and they'll give you an
entire month's supply for
free when you use promo code pacman just
pay five dollars for shipping